tout
alors bonjour la planète je salue la
planète vous allez c'est lui la planète
jusqu'à saluer lourd c'est une grosse
affaire alors ici on a à nouveau cette
semaine deuxième semaine d'affilée
alice chantal tandem qui est avec nous
du service français bonjour stéphane
notre envoyé spécial pour la première
fois l'émission on va vous expliquer un
peu plus tard à l'émission pourquoi elle
est le titre extraordinaire d'envoyé
spécial qui coûte rien maryse joubert
bonjour bonjour stéphane marie ce
travail aux services français de radio
canada international également à ce
service il ya du monde beaucoup de monde
dans ce service n'a il ya marie claude
qui est avec nous marie claude qui les
spécialistes du web
s'il n'était pas là et puis à part
madame simard il y à aussi claude gimeno
comme d'habitude et on a besoin donc
d'un autre ms pour la bonne diffusion de
cette émission je vous épargne les noms
des gens qui se trouvent ailleurs ils
sont aussi nombreux
alors aujourd'hui il vous connaissez la
tradition vous la connaissez oui ça fait
de soi nous est la risée rien j'ai la
découvrir et puis marie-claude elle
s'est donc on ne peut pas participer au
jeu mais ça s'appelle deviner de quoi on
parle aujourd'hui
leonardo vous savez beaucoup niveau
alors tous les internautes jouent en
même temps que nous on va regarder cette
petite vidéo préparée par radio canada
international avec des images qui
suggèrent le thème aujourd'hui vous
suggérez je réponds oui ou non vous
n'avez pas de seconde
la robotisation des soins ça pourrait
être ça ça vous des routes pas un peu
c'est pas tout à fait les infirmes et
qu'on voit dans les hôpitaux des
résidents qui sont épuisés
tout le monde fatigué sa part être ça
mon dieu ça s'aggrave
vous n'avez pas tout à fait le thème
mais je sais que vous le saviez dans
vous l'avez pas dit peut-être faire
jouer le jeu plein pour jouer quand on
joue aux brûlantes à un fermi qu'on
avait poussé des infirmiers et les
infirmières
bien sûr il ya les deux aujourd'hui et
alors justement on va avoir une invitée
spéciale pour nous parler de la
situation dans le domaine des infirmiers
et des infirmières et au canada au
québec surtout pour parler d'emploi de
perspectives d'emploi ça fait aussi du
soin aux patients ici on parle de crise
de crise aiguë en ce moment oui
c'est pas que les patients qui sont
malades mais aussi le service de santé
apparemment au québec
oui globalement qui serait peut-être à
l'agonie peut-être mais il faut pas
pousser trop loin trop loin non plus
c'est des gens qui font un travail
remarquable qui mérite d'être souligné
il ya même certains politiciens qui
disait des infirmières que c'était une
vocation
alors pendant de cette belle vocation la
première question il porte sur des
sommes infirmiers les hommes est fermé
on n'en parle jamais mais on les voit
souvent je suis à l'hôpital au joueur
accompagné une copine et puis avec un
copain aussi le fmi qui était fermé mais
qui était très stressé risque comme on
dit alors au canada les hommes pour les
hommes représentent quel pourcentage des
effectifs infirmiers et infirmières
autorisées travaillant en soins
infirmiers questions assez précises
maryse 5% 5 pour ça tu tirais 15%
attendait un peu là on va recommencer
ben oui avec notre belle lumière ça
c'est aux allures de guirlandes voilà
alors vous dites 5%
vous dites pour lui couper l'herbe sous
le pied 15 % 15 pensent pas très bien 10
pour ça c'est pour 28% et vous basis à
sur quoi exactement cela était de la
quantité des gens qui on voit dans les
obligeant les hôpitaux on se rend dans
les hôpitaux ils sont pas très nombreux
dans les couloirs c'est davantage les
femmes non jeter à l'hôpital souvent
mais
je vois pas beaucoup d hommes mais quand
même c'est pas une chaque 10 à voilà
c'est pas indispensable d'accord vous
passerez passé beaucoup de temps à
l'hôpital les leçons face à la
difficulté à évaluer c'est que y'a les
préposés ou les infirmiers les
infirmiers infirmières est là et tout
dépendant si on a des études collégiales
ou universitaires
oui il ya trois catégories
essentiellement d'infirmier on va en
parler l'émission vous devancé les
choses dans cette extraordinaire c'est
une spécialiste envoyé spécial comme mon
lit je tenais ce qu'elle soit là parce
que pour des raisons de santé elle a
souvent passé du temps à l'hôpital ça va
bien mais bon a besoin eu besoin de
soins donc l expérience ici qu'on a
peut-être pas tous ici autour de la
table alors elle a la bonne réponse 7%
5% en fait c'est 6 4%
donc c'est elle qui a la plus proche de
bonnes raisons cette première question
de notre quizz remuer voulait mettre les
ménages vont pour combien de % 20 %
vous lui accordez 20% mais oui alors
c'est 20 % c'est gagné et je vous donne
aujourd'hui donc un petit bout de papier
avec un crayon pour tenir compte de
votre évolution révolution dans
l'émission c'est comme une étoile
pratiquement parce qu'élu confusion dans
les autres émissions récemment où les
gens trafic est éventé réinventait
lorsque j'ai décidé d'y mettre fin à
tout jamais vous n'êtes pas pour notre
invité spécial tout à fait ce n'est pas
unie vite mystère parce que vous savez
dans quels domaines et le travail s'il
s'agit de lustre en tremblay présidente
depuis cinq ans de l'ordre des
infirmières et infirmiers du québec
manon tremblay bienvenue à tam tam
canada bonjour bonjour moi je vous
regarde là les autres vous regarde là
pas de problème mais tant qu'on pu
savoir la réalité c'est pour ça qu'on
vous a demandé de venir et je dois
absolument à dévoiler toute la vérité
moi maman est infirmière et à la pris sa
retraite récemment est ce que tu aurais
plus dur c'était de marcher marcher
marcher sur du ciment 1 à longueur de
journée aussi bouger des patients les
mais dans l'ensemble le système de santé
québécois par rapport aux soins que
pratique des infirmières
il ya des problèmes communs il ya une
crise qui semble faire des soucis des
tracas que un ensemble incroyable
d'infirmiers ensemble tout partagé fait
longtemps qu'on en parle mais là on
atteint la crise réelle
en fait de quoi vous parlez de votre
maman qui a été repéré qu'il trouvait ça
difficile je pense qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut souligner c'est que la profession
d'infirmière c'est une profession où est
ce que les un corner ont besoin de grand
g de grandes connaissances
elles ont des possibilités d'intervenir
qui sont immenses a sonné l'heure du
début de la vie à la fin de la vie on
est là surtout les quarts de travail les
jours fériés ainsi de suite
alors on a besoin de leur expertise leur
expertise qui est unie et en ce moment
la crise qui nous occupe ce que les uns
comme leur dise je suis pas capable de
respecter mes obligations
professionnelles pour répondre à ces
besoins le qui sont complexes
alors nous comme infirmière l'on sent
déchiré quand on n'est pas capable de
faire ce pour quoi on a été formé ce pas
ce que ce que la population s'attend
nous qu'on les soigne avec toute la
compétence du congo alors les infirmiers
et les infirmières nous appelle en ce
moment en disant bien que je veuille le
faire
je suis plus en mesure de faire toutes
sortes de raisons sont les indices sur
le terrain et les statistiques et il ya
beaucoup de coeur personnel mais quel
genre d'image on peut on peut on peut
donner leur rapport à ce qui se passe
sur le terrain
c'est tellement important ce moment on
n'est même plus à compter on est dans
une situation qui est tout à fait
inusitée ou est-ce que les gens sont
prêt à s'auto dénoncé de dire qu'ils
doivent donner l'exemple concret le mois
par exemple infirmières travaillent sur
une unité de soins ou est-ce que les
priorités sont nombreuses et elle doit
faire des choix quels soins elle va
donner et qu'elle soit elle ne donne
repos alors elle se sent complètement
d'echery parce que tout ça est important
mais aussi le public parce que un autre
professionnel ces dates pour protéger
public par la compétence des
actionnaires le public nous avons besoin
on les voit là ils sont pas capables de
répondre à nos besoins c'est pas
qu'elles veulent pas ils sont partout
ils sont déchirés en différentes
priorités
on doit faire quelque chose il nous
comme comment professionnels je lui ai
dit on trace on s'assure de la
compétence des infirmiers avec un new
deal
j'ai la compétence mais je pas capable
de le faire on à devoir d'informer le
ministère de la santé et des services
sociaux fsss et sont de fait hier en
allant rencontrer et en luttant d'argent
ces inquiétudes très importantes comme
au basket c'est déjà les ouïes à madame
tremblay je voudrais vous demander parce
que moi j'ai utilisé les services dans
les hôpitaux
est ce que c'est pour cette raison parce
que sont à bout de souffle que souvent
maintenant il ya beaucoup d'infirmières
qui n'acceptera pas de temps plein parce
qu'elles ne veulent pas être obligé de
faire du temps obligatoire ou de rester
en poste plus que 8 heures j'aimerais ça
vous donner une réponse simple parce que
moi j'ai fait le tour du québec à
plusieurs reprises est ce que les
internats qui travaille sur les unités
de soins midi c'est oui on veut avoir
des temps plein mais j'entends aussi
aujourd'hui qu'il ya des postes sont
libres et qu'elle ne postule pas et le
phénomène de temps supplémentaire comme
vous dites le petit obligatoires
c'est vraiment un problème majeur et
souvent c'est un carnet elles seront
contraintes en disant c'est ton code
déontologique t'oblige de rester alors
que ce n'est pas le corps le code de
déontologie guy le baube situations là
d'exception catastrophique et quand
l'infirmière à midi je vous donne encore
quelque chose de très très réel il y en
a qui se lèvent le matin qui est pas
nécessairement en quarts de travail et
je serai du lait à la vente vont voir
contraint garderie toutes les
commissions petit peu de ménage prépare
les landes à deux ans l'après midi le
centre l'appel dit j'ai besoin de toi 4
à 30,2 chavez en votre réveil y fait son
chiffre de 4 heures à minuit à minuit on
lui dit tu dois rester
c'est sûr qu'on lui demande pas de
travailler 24 heures consécutives mais
ça personne ne pas avoir été éveillés
pendant 24 heures consécutives
alors quand on nous appelle à la besace
je suis prise entre l'herbe et les
courses quand on me dit que je dois
faire en temps supplémentaire je me sens
pas en mesure de faire
de déontologie call c'est l'infirmière
qui qui considère qu'un apport et pourra
à donner des soins de qualité doit le
dire et doit refuser de travailler et là
on est vraiment pris entre l'arbre et
les corses
c'est quelque chose qu'on est clair
qu'il ya avec les ministres ce pas une
façon de willow me laisse paraître
c'est pas une façon d'organiser les
services de toujours devoir se fier sur
du stade clément chantôme madame
tremblay vous parliez tantôt de
pourparlers avec le ministère de la
santé
nous aimerions savoir où est-ce que vous
en êtes avec ces négociations là surtout
en ce qui concerne le défi du nombre
parce que si les infirmières achève la
journée sur pratiquement sur les rotules
c'est parce qu'elles ne sont pas assez
nombreuses pour relever les multiples
défis qui s'imposent à eux encore une
fois situation complexe parce que le
nombre d'infirmières habitants au québec
et plus nombreux qu'ailleurs dans
l'ensemble du canada
est ce qu'on les utilise toujours à bon
escient est-ce qu'on utilise toute leur
expertise sur ces photos je claque dans
les discussions qu'on a eues avec le
ministre real s'était justement comment
utiliser à bon escient ses compétences
là et il ya des infirmiers des internats
qui sont disponibles en format aps c de
l'information que seul l'ordre passé on
sait qu'il ya des diplômés hors québec
donc des infirmiers et des infirmières
qui ont été formés à l'extérieur du
canada qui viennent s'installer ici et
nous on dit par exemple une formation ou
des compétences qui sont équivalents ils
doivent aller faire un stage pour
comprendre le système de santé québécois
est où il doit faire un programme
d'actualisation qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
passer à travers cette étape il ya 1200
ces personnes qui sont en attente de
compléter le stage imaginé comme un
mille deux cents personnes aujourd'hui
ça pourrait amener un vrai chat dans
notre réseau et la wii on parle de gens
par exemple qui ont eu leur diplôme en
france ou même en afrique du nord en
tunisie en algérie
situé dans les différents pays du monde
on reçoit des demandes est bon chaque
cas est étudié au colloque est selon la
la formation l'expérience qu'ont ses
jambes et on va leur demander d'aller
faire ce programme de formation le pied
très court de quelques semaines mais il
faut quand même y passent à travers les
années les grandes différences entre le
système santé à d'ailleurs ici au canada
qu'il va faire que ces gens là il puisse
pas rentrer dans le système il ya des
différences même temps parce que fait
une infirmière au québec
l'autonomie de l'infirmière est très
basse on est les seuls professionnels
avec les médecins qui ont la capacité
d'évaluer la condition physique et
mentale
l'infirmière du québec or une grande
autonomie pour décider des soins
ce qui n'est pas nécessairement le cas
partout à travers le monde
une des particularités en trop c'est que
certaines des actionnaires du québec ont
le droit d'inscrire par exemple on
utilise aussi des ordonnances
collectives qui donne une grande
autonomie à l'infirmière ou l'infirmier
a décidé soins et la composition de
l'équipe de soins a peut être aussi
différent d'ailleurs d'allemand une
dernière question
moi j'allais vous demander quels sont
vos principales pistes de solutions pour
améliorer les conditions de travail des
infirmières les conditions de travail
c'est pas un autre professionnel que ce
que c'est les emplois là c'est le
syndicat nous on est vraiment dans la
posture de dire utilisant toute la
compétence de l'infirmière permettons
lui de l'ufas qu'elle exposait pas mais
aussi c'est que peu peau est constamment
en porte-à-faux entre les conditions
d'exercice dans laquelle l heure les
obligations professionnelles et c'est
inacceptable une situation comme celle
là il faut qu'elles soient en nombre
suffisant pilon une solution à
d'ailleurs déjà que pour être disponible
rapidement
il faut qu'elle soit au bon endroit est
ce que on les utilise toujours ou est ce
qu'elles sont des créateurs de valeur il
ya un travail à faire et ça se règle au
pot avec une seule rencontre avec le
ministre il s'est engagé à nous
rencontrer régulièrement au cours des
prochaines semaines pour qu'on s'assure
justement de ce qu'elles soient pas
toujours coincé entre l'arbre et
l'écorcé mon dieu alors conduit le
combat vous êtes vous vous défendez vous
vous battez pour tous les tous ceux qui
sont d'éventuels patients c'est nous
sommes
probablement tous ces partis alors merci
infiniment d'avoir d'avoir été là
aujourd'hui d'avoir fait votre première
entrevue sur skype félicitations c'est
vrai la raison ils sont plus pop et plus
populaire s'applique ici
merci beaucoup madame de trembler puis à
la prochaine peut-être alors si tremblay
présidente de l'ordre des infirmiers et
infirmières du québec à 24% 27 % de tous
les infirmiers masculin au canada ils
sont au québec alors que le québec ne
représentent que 23 24 % de la
population
alors ça vous montre qu'ils sont plus
une société plus certainement problème
vraiment important oui cette histoire
d'infirmière exténué fatigué avec des
journées très très compliqué donc je
trouve que l a du pain sur la planche
madame tremblay voulez vous que je vous
remonte le moral un peu aller chercher
une pilule d'énergie chez un collègue de
radio canada vous donnez un nom
peut-être ça vous dire quelque chose
maryse vincent maisonneuve
vincent maisonneuve de la verrie
exactement c'est une jeune équipe une
ils s'intéressent beaucoup ils font des
affaires ericsson sont parfaites sur
toutes sortes de sujets forts mais c'est
une façon pour comprendre plus
rapidement les enjeux on donne des
points spécifiques ils le font en
général en 2009 un second nous on les a
corsé cutter arrêté du encore parce que
nous autres on les spécialistes
finalement du raccourci et donc je pense
qu en une minute il va nous donner une
idée encore plus précise de ce problème
de la relève qui est pas au rendez vous
que dès qu'il veille à un instant notre
invité voici d'entre eux vidéo et depuis
quatre ans les nouvelles infirmières qui
elle intègre le marché du travail sont
moins en moins nombreuses à choisir un
poste à temps plein voici les chiffres
en 2013 47% des nouvelles infirmières
ont décroché un poste à temps plein soit
environ 1300 infirmières l'an dernier
seulement 19 % des nouvelles recrues ont
choisi une charge à temps complet soit
peinard
nouvelles infirmières refusent carrément
des postes parce qu'avec une charge à
temps plein ils ont l'obligation en plus
de faire du temps supplémentaire ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour les infirmières
qui choisissent des postes à temps
partiel ou encore des postes
occasionnels alors voilà pour les
chiffres maintenant le jeu on repart le
jeu deuxième manche de notre jeu remuez
vous l'aimez neige
et voici vous avez tous vos blocs notes
et vos pieds vous vos crayons pour
écrire oui en fait un parfait alors
aussi c'est assez académique mon affaire
mais c'est pour rejoindre l'idée que
commencer à développer plutôt une
émission marie chauvet au niveau des
différents types d'un fermier ou
d'infirmières qui est ici au canada il y
en a en principe trois vous allez en
général ceux dépendant de votre problème
nous allons rencontrer un ou une ou
plusieurs de ces deux sites spécialisés
infirmières et les infirmiers tout court
qui détiennent un diplôme d'études
collégiales en soins infirmiers ça c'est
à peu près trois ans d'études et bi leur
salaire horaire c'est entre 21 dollar
etc 32 dollars d'accord ça vous donne
une idée ici c'est pas un métier pour
les pauvres
on peut soutenir une famille avec ça et
aussi au niveau un peu plus une coche
plus élevé si vous voulez au niveau des
responsabilités
les infirmières et infirmiers cliniciens
qui sont diplômés d'un bac à lorient
science aaas est comme moi trois ans
d'études ça suffit ont donc parlé le
ministre bêtes n'ont pas tout à fait ça
n'est pas tout à fait parce que là on a
vu leur salaire assez assez non super
infirmières mais toujours mais quand
même cliniciens ses 22 $ 40 $ de l'heure
ce seuil en deçà là au dessus de la
moyenne à 40 dollars au dessus de la
moyenne horaire du salaire horaire des
canadiens sont autour de 27 de lens mes
souvenirs sont bons
beta troisième catégorie c'est encore
une coche plus élevé au niveau des
responsabilités
alors si les infirmiers en praticiennes
spécialisées d'accord peu moins nombreux
au québec pour des raisons qu'il faudra
peut-être exercé avec un prochain éviter
et puis mais quand même très populaire
ça correspond au niveau de cinq années
d'études universitaires c'est là que ça
prend une master sérieuse et gagnent un
salaire qui peut atteindre 92 milliard
800 salles sur salaire de base ça c'est
sans les heures supplémentaires
obligatoires
et lorsqu'on parle de paris par exemple
une infirmière qui serait dans des
champs opératoires
en fait c'est des infirmières qui se
rapproche davantage des médecins oui
socialiser tout à fait alors voici ma
question combien gagnent ces infirmières
lesquels lesquels les dernières parce
que vous avez parlé de serre de 80 12
nuls juge pas c'est votre réponse vous
l'avez dit j'ai inventé oui
ouais sauf que l'oeuvre votre tête tenir
compte des heures supplémentaires
qu'elles font je sais pas répondait
comme vous pouvez m'en je dirais sans
ennemi sans 20092 mais je vous l'avais
dit qu'est-ce que je continue quatre ans
ex non ça sinon d'accord c'est pas 95
je cherchais la bonne réponse entière
entre 50000 92000 si vous avez 10 92 me
j'accepte ma part rien inventé ces
défauts des questions sont truquées
ajouté 30% s'il est super vous me donnez
vos photos pour que je moi je continue à
suivre
non mais si on fait des bonds de 20 il
ya pas de crainte pour son annonce et la
première 7,20 faut pas compliqué il faut
pas changer les règles
vous l'avez fait deux fois de suite non
non 30% cette fois-ci 20% la dernière
fois vous avez eu 20 % la dernière fois
non j'étais encore un peu pour ça non
la dernière fois la dernière fois
j'avais fait une bonne avocate mois
peut-être alors 20% 50% pour madame
jobin vous avez vous aviez des réponses
82 les jeux ouais ouais non j'étais un
peu plus parce que je pensais qu'on
devait tenir quand les heures
supplémentaires 1 % mais j'avais vous
0,7 compensant pour ça parce que j'ai 10
92 alors vous avez 30 % je lis façon
inscrit sur les cartes pascal canfin
mais pourquoi elle aurait 30 % et moi
juste 1% je comprends avez vous donné la
bonne réponse est oui j'ai pas de 92 % -
vous avez parlé de 92%
82 20 % samedi on va vous laisser passer
tout au fond ici ça c'est être sur le
même pied d'égalité que madame a décidé
comme vous voulez à ce moment ci je
n'apprenais partance de tous des
gagnants pour moi je perds la prochaine
question après question déterminera le
grand gagnant
je pensais que ça allait solutionner le
problème je vois que ça a compliqué les
choses
on va continuer comme ça si ça vous
tente
voici une invitation que vous lance ce
charmant un fort un infirmier c'est au
chum centre hospitalier universitaire ne
vaut rien on regarde la publicité je
pense qu'un peu de son mais on a dû lui
enlever peut-être pour des raisons de
copyright
alors voilà où liam un fermier nouvel
hôpital très important et il dit vient
travailler avec moi ou nouveaux chemins
très sympathique avec tout ce que vous
avez entendu ça vous tente
ce que vous feriez le saut peut-être
pour des raisons humanitaires oui bon on
va pas très bien des obstacles pour
servir quelque chose dans la société
surtout auprès des bons plus nécessiteux
à la raison vous pouvez utiliser les
gens ou servir les gens c'est le choix
qu'ont fait dans la vie marine
mais je passe une question d'avoir le
sens du bien commun
la question reste à savoir ce qu'on va
avoir une vie de famille si oui
peut-être qu'on voudra pas être
permanente et qu'on voudra garder le
contrôle heures et les journées qu'on
fait ou sinon on y va à plaît mais moi
j'en ai rencontré beaucoup qui le font
de façon permanente etc cent des
personnes extraordinaires fantastique
marie-claude je crois pas que j'ai la
force psychologique pour être infirmière
mais j'admire beaucoup leur travail mais
côtoyer comme ça les gens qui
souffraient tous les jours ça doit être
très disque c'est sûrement une
personnalité vraiment ce décès à gérer
préfet jeu oui je serais pas capable
ça n'est pas capable aider oui mais
travaillé comme infirmière pilote
toujours la cote et des gens qui
souffrent moi j'ai un vieil ami
d'enfance avec lequel je re nouer des
relations sur skype
il ya un an qui habite en alberta
maintenant et qui a changé de vocation
il devenu infirmier a surpris un peu
parce qu'il était dans l' plutôt genre
je comptais remet un peu ennuyé je vais
demander quand je patine juge 90 pour
moi ce sera un mur c'est sûr mais je lui
ai demandé pourquoi quand tu dois
nettoyer les gens qui sont malades parce
qu'il s'occupe des gens qui meurent
c'était provence ou comment tu fais pour
ne pas être complètement désespéré où il
dit je les regarde dans les yeux
c'est comme avec comme ça que je
communique avec ces gens là en fait il
est à bien vrai contact sa personne
et puis c'est une question de
sensibilité personnelle aussi un calque
parce qu'il faut être proche des gens il
faut aimer les gens
il faut avoir beaucoup d'empathie pour
pouvoir exercer ce métier là parce que
c'est pas donné à tout le monde c'est un
métier qui demande beaucoup d'amour
beaucoup d'affection beaucoup de
disponibilité oui et ça demande aussi
une facilité communication et de l'
écoute et lorsque madame tremblay quand
vous parlez du rôle important des
infirmiers et infirmières l'écoutent
entre les différents spécialistes
spécifiquement entre les médecins et des
infirmières et ce serait très important
des fois que les médecins se sert de
l'information que détiennent déjà les
infirmières pour que le système
fonctionne normalement tout à fait c'est
très positif face ont présenté la sphère
j'apprécie énormément
c'est un travail qui demande aussi
beaucoup de collaborations entre ces
différents corps là cette semaine je
parlais des médecins résidents qui sont
ces jeunes là qui sont souvent en stage
et qui sont très souvent intimidés
que ce soit par les médecins par les
infirmiers donc comme je dis c'est un
travail d'équipé il faut tenir compte de
tous ceux qui interviennent des
différents maillons de la chaîne
on va élargir un peu le propos de
l'émission on va aller vers la question
tam tam
elle était plus vous menu un peu plus
tard à l'émission mais nous sommes pas
un problème on n'est pas comme à la
télévision que changer les choses les
matchs de placement
et voici non on présentera pas ça
aujourd'hui vous l'avez pas la question
à tam tam la voilà on va demander donne
une heure lire la question je vois pas
vu un ferme et un pompier ambulancier au
policier qui a les plus touchées votre
vie racontez nous pourquoi
[Musique]
j'sais pas si pour ceux qui veulent
poursuivre la conversation la question
et sur la page facebook de tam-tam
canada on peut élargir la conversation
j'avais habité
je sais pas ce grenu peut-être la
semaine prochaine on pourrait paris
départ des policiers jeu sinon bah ce
sera autre chose mais tu n'es qu'un jour
on devrait officier des pompiers moi
j'adore parce que j'avais 15 ans la
maison est partie ou feraient partie
open 1er janvier c'est un super héros
quelque part mr total mais quelle
rapidité pour essayer d éviter que le
sang ne se propage aux autres et dessus
c'est une montée sur les toits pour
aller avec l'âge pour ouvrir pour que
l'air puisse sortir enfin céder c'est un
point incroyable mais sauf que ces
derniers temps les informations qui
proviennent de ce côté là ne sont pas du
tout rassurantes en ce qui concerne la
santé de ces personnes
oui ces trois semaines on est à l'affût
mais les grands singes et aux cancers et
toutes sortes de surtout le fait que
maintenant les gens de plus en plus
d'outils technologiques à la maison et
que dans ses soutes outils
technologiques comme on utilise des
tablettes
eh bien il ya des substances très
toxiques seyman lorsque des feux alors
c'est ça devienne plus un petit set
on va aller dans un endroit on retrouve
les trois les policiers les ambulanciers
et les infirmières même les médecins ne
faut pas les oublier il faut quand même
pas très sérieux alors voici j'ai appelé
ça un jeu un jeu de mots sur un titre de
roman très connus dont j'ignore
absolument l'auteur mais j'ai appelé ça
dernier de cordée
ou plutôt premier corps des derniers
corps des jeunes et vous comprendre
pourquoi à la fin
pourquoi ça s'appelle comme ça voici un
vendredi soir à l'hôpital d'urgence à
montréal un patients sur civière arrive
à l'hôpital général de montréal deux
poêles ici que suit le patient était jt
violent gardienne sécurité sont dépêchés
pour le stabiliser
[Musique]
libre les corridors sont pleins les
patients sur civière surtout même dans
la salle d'attenté on à l'espace pour 13
patients dans la salle présentement il y
en a 24
c'est s'allient pour les patients qui
doit être sur moniteur qui sont cordes
et le sur blanc il n'existe pas de norme
des espaces pour les patients dans les
hôpitaux en amérique
non mais c'est que lire certains camps
de réfugiés qui ont plus de ce pass pour
mes patients que ceux ici à montréal que
dans nos hôpitaux rien ça mais je fais
les choses un peu en perspective tout à
fait c'est un travail d'équipé chacun à
sa place
on appelle ces derniers mois j'ai déjà
passé toute une soirée intime couloirs
des hôpitaux
c'est vrai ça m'est arrivé de passer
presque kw à 12 heures dans l'entrée de
dunant by larm apporte une ambiance mais
d'une défense pataude intensifs mais
vers l'urgence et mon lit était entre la
porte vers les toilettes des femmes
publics et la fin des toilettes des
femmes des hommes et là les gens se
promenaient et entre nous il y avait
sûrement des petits rideaux alors on
voyait tout le monde entrer sortir
disons que là on oublie côté privé et
puis c'est çà et là il y avait quelqu'un
pas très loin qui elle vomissait essayer
de gérer tout seul que personne ne
contamine personnes
c'est pas évident à l'heure du lunch et
dans 20 minutes donc on va dire mais
c'est tellement entré ce que vaut mieux
en rire dont l'un est prêt pour notre
troisième je remets vous les méninges
non c'est sérieux la jeune âge qui me
venait en tête comment raconter ces
histoires là les médecins qui se
plaignent du manque de délimiter pour
particuliers de deux cas de problème
d'un patient vous avez telle affaire et
les plus longs qui a ménagé
c'est cette histoire je me rappelle
j'étais toute une soirée aussi
accompagné en persan qui parlait pas les
français de l'anglais alors on a passé
toute la journée à passer toute la
la nuit avec cette personne je
l'accompagnais parce qu'il parlait pas
les langues officielles du canada puis
on était dans une endroit il y avait
huit civières comme ça puis on était
trois mois j'étais au milieu des tout à
côté de la personne qui était malade qui
il ya des tours des gens qui a des
problèmes respiratoires et des gens qui
viennent des d'abord l'accident tout ça
autour d'un passant qui essaient de se
calmer parce que imaginez la scène c'est
à cause d'une gestion chaotique de
l'espace on va dire il ya beaucoup de
faits aussi que le parc immobilier des
hôpitaux est vieillissant comme par
exemple on peut prendre un exemple de
l'hôpital maisonneuve rosemont annoncés
dont on parlait ce matin on se retrouve
à deux patients dans des chambres qui
ont été conçus pour une personne seule
alors lorsque vous rajouter tout
l'équipement technologique qui est
disponible maintenant c'est très
difficile pour les gens de circuler et
il faut penser aussi qu'à chaque année
au canada
il arrive quoi 205 à 1300 nous nouvelles
personnes
on y prend avec des hôpitaux qui a été
conçu dans les années 50 et on n'est pas
capable de répondre à la demande et on a
pendant des années
couper les budgets provinciaux et
fédéraux aude au coupé dans ce qu'on
pouvait investir dans les soins de santé
actéon peu avant d'aller au jour
peut-être avoir un petit reportage de
radio-canada du reportage d'époque pour
montrer pourquoi on en parle depuis 20
ans de ceux de ce problème c'est ça on
parle de crise mon appareil à 20 ans on
va voir à qui on en parle encore
aujourd'hui alors je parle de ça les
racines du mal debout jusqu'au bout on
contient fort voici
ce n'est pas d'hier que les infirmières
se plaignent d'être surchargé au milieu
des années 90 le gouvernement bouchard
met en place le virage ambulatoire
ce que nous annonçons aujourd'hui c'est
un coup de barre détermine un des
hôpitaux ferment leurs portes
les autres doivent composer avec des
départs de personnels massif sur 390
nous avons 85 des milliers d'infirmières
comme leur retraite
en l'espace de quelques mois l'effectif
au québec passe de 64 mille infirmières
en 1995 à 59 milles en 1988 en 1999
elles entreprennent une grève illégale
les infirmières dénoncent leurs
conditions de travail et réclament de
meilleurs salaires
nous préférons être debout juste debout
jusqu'au bout et puis là avant eux
disent qu'elles sont à bout écoutez on
est prêt pour le dernier jeu on veut
juste de parler de jeu dans le contexte
mais en tout cas un dernier examen de la
question d'examen voici alors sa porte
sur à quel point les choses s'améliorent
le gouvernement québécois se vanter en
2010 est d'avoir réussi à diminuer le
temps d'attenté dans les urgences les a
vus les engeances qu'elle était en heure
la durée moyenne du séjour sur civière
dans un hôpital québécois en 2017 on va
faire le tour
on va commencer par les eaux gimeno 50%
pour l'examen vous pourriez remporter le
trophée aujourd'hui 16 à 16 16
vous avez de l'expérience l'expérience
12 à 12 heures moi je dirai quand je
serai peut-être plus proche d un devin
way qui dit 24 heures mois plus de 24
heures toutes mes excuses
mais par expérience avec mon fils qui a
passé plus de 24
c'est vrai
et voilà et deux autres mineurs on
attend plus longtemps et on ne peut-être
pas au bon endroit
non mais j'étais avec ma fait j'aime
cassé on était huit heures puis ils nous
disent si vous voulez aller dormir à la
main son pied à l'élément l'élan des
cliniques privées ça va être mieux mais
moi j'ai un secret pour vous j'ai dû
aller à l'urgence deux fois depuis six
ans et plus à faire de rien du tout moi
je suis un bûcheron et amendé il ya une
tique qui s'est accrochée à moi puis
j'ai perdu c'est comprendre quand ça
commence à sucer le sang c'est dangereux
alors je me suis c'est ce qu'on dit
allez à l'urgence mais juste deux fois
c'est une bonne nouvelle une excellente
nouvelle pour vous le bas alors je suis
allé en ontario parce que j'habite pas
loin comme vous le savez que j'ai dit si
mais pas loin et j'ai attendu la
première fois je pense 30 secondes deux
secondes à issigeac aggrave terminal
mais vu d'accord je vais y aller
la deuxième fois ça a été un peu plus
long je doive pas c'était ou 30 minutes
ouais ouais encore chanceux ouais et
puis une fois chalet avec une même une
amie puis la recette est long ça a été
deux heures au québec la durée moyenne
qui a répondu en 13 heures ou 15 heures
j'ai dit dès 12 mois je décèle pas mal
pareil vous avez 50 % c'est les grands
gagnants mais afin que 55 ans et les
deux grands gagnants l'émission nous
avons perdu maryse et ses débats des
hôpitaux en vain parce qu'elle est gros
capitaux on n'atteint plus longtemps ce
n'est pas aussi avec l'affection
spectacle que sais je suis professeur
d'allemand et puis ça dépend celle de
l'infirmière qui fait le triage
c'est parce que ça peut être des fois
très aléatoire non pas vrai il ya des
codes la des priorités et si cac 40 est
vraiment est en danger ça prend pas de
temps on peut pas lui soutien bruyant du
100 $
non mais on peut avoir des idées des
patients qui simule une urgence ont
nommé jean cette raison que je parle les
ses yeux se posent pas les attendre
d'accord donc alors écoutez je vais on
va terminer sur ces images et aussi de
musique à voir ça m'inquiète parce que
vous connaissez la politique de a à f à
c'est bo au capot pas le nommer d'accord
non politique c'est quand il ya de la
musique qui ont fait un live très vous
prenez un risque extraordinaire comme
couple le signal en coupe les pattes
mais je pense pas que ce soit il n'y a
pas de cette une c'est déjà sur youtube
donc il ya copyright et déjà s'est
réduit et puis on a fait un petit
montage aussi alors je pense qu'il n'y a
pas de problème mais au cas où il y en a
je pense qu a pas de problème en interne
et là dessus parce que c'est une
publicité pour inviter les gens qui
seraient par exemple à l'étranger comme
s'il avait besoin d'arguments
additionnel à venir travailler comme
infirmier ou infirmière au québec un
capitaine ça s'appelle sacré hôpital
voilà au sacré coeur non se saper
l'hôpital du sacré-coeur à montréal on
regarde
[Musique]
je suis une première la dernière chose
jamais jamais
[Musique]
il s'en fout
m
[Musique]
oh
allez on y danse 1 ça bougeait pas
beaucoup ça dure plus longtemps mais
évidemment pour des raisons de copyright
il fallait limiter le plaisir merci
beaucoup pour cette semaine je vous
remercie stéphane chantal jean d'esme du
services français de radio-canada
merci radio canada international wine
précis marie jo balle envoyée spéciale
ainsi beaucoup vous pour autant que je
vois pas envoyé trop spécialement les
hôpitaux à marie-claude à la prochaine
merci et ogier mène la gagner vous êtes
où les caméras pour dire on voit là par
là
[Musique]